[Music]
desperate times news oh it's always
desperate desperate times calls for
desperate measures
yep thank you this sounds like a Tom
Clancy novel yep submitted by a dancer
of poles oh it sounds like a dancer from
Poland play a game of Thrones title it's
a game of Thrones stripper on the
ancient wench I bet you make hella money
on it yep for $5,000 you can go on a
bigfoot and alien excursion with Jose
Canseco baseball baseball is this in
like New Mexico or sighs got to make
money man exactly XML B baby ain't pay
no more what does have to do with
safaris oh dear you don't get that big
playing [ __ ] baseball
dude he's injected that [ __ ] into his
face he's doing [ __ ] forehead listen
super tiny he looks like a baseball
glove yes so you tweeted this out
recently so it says I want to go come
play golf with me and learn about aliens
and time-traveling how's the job spend
the day with Jose come hang out with me
ask me questions pick my brain to see
what I'm really about contact more again
at 7:02 three seven four three you know
some [ __ ] yeah we know when you're in
Vegas come and let me teach you the art
of power hitting with a baseball and
softball contact Morgan above that
sounds fun don't spend the day with me
and my alien buddies
I'll show you Bigfoot and a real alien
called Morgana who the [ __ ] is Morgan go
on a book Bigfoot and alien excursion
Jose Canseco I know there was Bigfoot in
Vegas I didn't know Bigfoot and aliens
are clapping like that the communities
tend to cross collab yeah it's kind of
like skateboarders and surfers mm-hmm oh
that's how close they have big food
surfing so then Huffington Post called
the number that he keeps listing and you
received they received this text
messages message that says spend the
weekend with Jose for $5,000 cash only
five lucky individuals will get a golden
ticket Oompa Loompas ain't got nothing
on Bigfoot
travel and his custom RV to authentic
alien sightings and proven Bigfoot
habitats camp
out in the wild tell stories and maybe
meet a real boom but I want to never
know what's gonna happen with mr.
Canseco parenthesis food included only
serious enquiries please I will help
this sounds fine with him specifically
him does he also make me ham and cheese
sandwich because it sounds like lunch is
provided right and it's custom RVs like
an old-school Winnebago or some [ __ ]
this is like the most ghetto fire
festival ever
I know that's why I want to do it that's
good I would do it I would 5000 yeah
this is an experience of my life in
dollars and you're in Vegas already so
it's like do I spend $5,000 with this
man in his like making for Breaking Bad
RV can you meet a legendary baseball I'm
often can I throw away $5,000 chips not
very often right yes you could always go
to Vegas and blow $5,000 on gambling
that's always gonna be there if you did
Jenkins Hagel telling you about Bigfoot
yep that's not always gonna be showing
you know real alien trying to commit to
what it's really a lien is exactly why
you think he just has like a Mexican
[ __ ] or something and then he's like
see ya a real alien and he's underneath
the garbage can or something he's like
running right in the garbage spend their
little [ __ ] arms my name is Oscar
alien you should travel every bucket
never got some awful roids and [ __ ] you
should have time travel and just won the
lottery yesterday is money or something
so you said these aliens are going to
teach us how to try and travel the brain
weight how to try and travel the brain
can't physically travel without the body
that food needs to learn go back in
space I don't [ __ ] it sounds like some
DMT she's trying to teach us how to time
travel but first we have to change our
body composition which we are not
willing to do we have tried with animals
and it has failed
time travel puts 42,000 for steroids
whew one pound with Jose Canseco contact
market only when the human body is at
its most staff trouble all the body
brothers
withstand the [ __ ] people the
g-forces dude your [ __ ] time machine
scribbling Frick's
does this guy need mental help no he
needs money
baseball camps for like kids or at high
school there's or something he would
probably make way more the thing is he's
not passionate about that anymore he's
burnt out with baseball he's been doing
it he's on to new [ __ ] and the new [ __ ]
is exposing the lies of the government
yeah aliens and the Bigfoots dude I've
seen big it's real is it no I don't know
did you pay $5,000 to go see it that's
what the Jose Canseco is gonna do is
gonna make this it's worth barefoot
[ __ ] barefoot
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he [ __ ] eats here
how awesome is it like how like it's
like having Chris Brown talk to you
about area 51 and doing a tour yep like
wall singing and dancing yeah when it
should be is Chris Brown teaching
women's self-defense class that's more
oh boy so usually I would go for the
right hook but you take steroids yeah
I'll go teach that I think that
transition out what I would have done
with my legs is and then go just like
how I would have done it if I'm gonna
get a Rihanna right here yeah I'll show
you how I really went down you could
dress up as Rihanna and he'll show you I
need to I need to go to more shows like
this that's good why do you need this is
the sort of [ __ ] that we love then I
don't see am I just wired different cuz
you understand the contrast I just don't
know how to put a label on it but other
people they go oh this is like sad or
wrong or whatever I'm like this is
[ __ ] but the best thing in the world
yeah he's so down in the dumps that he
has to do this I loved and and you could
pay to watch this happen
and he [ __ ] did he selling you some
[ __ ] and you're sitting there like [ __ ]
yeah probably get him to put on an
impromptu magic show yeah like you're
paying an installment so we brought the
little cups
like hey make me do magic show you like
yeah he actually adds it into his future
acts dude exactly yeah
what if it's like a really fun tour then
you could go to the [ __ ] Grand Canyon
any bits all that [ __ ] and at the very
end he does a magic show
pull the [ __ ] devout and [ __ ] it
flies away yeah I love it this is just
like do you guys hear about that story
where you could get [ __ ] kiss to come
to your house through some cash and
there's their costumes think it's full
regalia but it could be wrong yeah what
they have is it's like this box you buy
this [ __ ] box it's got like all like
$6,000 so all 600 including their disco
album yeah everything and it's like me
and this like custom case and like
there's only like 600 of these getting
made ever right so then they were doing
infomercials on TV it's like have gene
Simmons and kiss come to your [ __ ]
house and like though they'll hang out
with you and a party or whatever the
[ __ ] yeah it's real and you just be like
5 right that's tragic it's pretty good
that's what babe I'm out so they're all
and they come to you which ones a better
deal this one are getting kissed yes
yeah I think it's kiss is even better I
like this just the laughs oh I laugh at
both how I would have kissed over and
then we do karaoke and I would do I
would have all my friends doing karaoke
you all who kiss has to sit there or we
pick a band that kiss [ __ ] hates we
play their music the whole time so we
all do Aerosmith there were like Gino
Steven Tyler what if you were Steve
Italian you paid this to girls like just
like like like look at my look at all
this like money and [ __ ] out oh
that's so good yeah Ryan you truly
devious from the bottom of my heart a
company that I work for has a
relationship with Steven Tyler really
was he cool I never met him but we had a
custom case built for him to send over
his whole crew and all that and it was
like all arrows went smooth [ __ ] like
whatever right and then I was in charge
of shipping that and it was a Pelican
case so all I did is go people ship this
I just made a [ __ ] slap on top I just
slapped it on top and sent it but the
whole point was to give him this nice
pellet Dobies with the Aerosmith decal
everything and it was all [ __ ]
scratch she got their asses and then the
whole time my manager and everyone
thought it was one of the day laborers
that did it and I'm sitting there like
they're getting mad right I can't
believe this [ __ ] and then I'm like I'm
like yeah that's [ __ ] up I couldn't
take it anymore and I was like actually
you told oh actually that was me I sent
it but the look on his face cuz the
whole time he was like [ __ ] I can't
believe those guys [ __ ] don't have a
brain all this stuff and I was like
sorry it was me cuz else at first I was
like on on it with them like yeah I
can't believe it and then I was it was
eating it was eating me inside I can't
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] and I was like
actually yeah I was the one that sent it
and he went from oh man he's like well
ok we'll try to make this better for him
and whatever yeah yeah like show that
even gentleman oh [ __ ] that's the
coolest boss Stevie to be on that
conference call in a picture oh you know
what I would pay for I would pay for
karate lessons from Steven Seagal me too
what's the martial art that he like you
know those tweets no no he's been
tweeting crazy [ __ ] yeah he's been clean
I forgot about him after the 90s so in
2012 he tweeted I actually died 2012
really weren't that far back yes alright
yeah I actually died overnight and came
back to life now I'm a vampire and you
are my apprentice and then he said when
I die and I saw Elvis and Michael they
said hello
holy [ __ ]
like in December of last year he tweeted
that some aliens deleted my account and
that he was trying to run for president
but then he said Jose we do not want you
to run for president you're destined for
much greater things in the battle
against the androids and the alien
masters elements of the United States
government are compromised by the
androids and aliens they are deeply and
at all levels cannot trust I have a
classmate that was batshit crazy like
this
yeah same yeah in my ceramics class so
we would be making pottery in a non this
[ __ ] so he looks like you know
the the Guy Fawkes masks the V for
Vendetta mask
imagine a fat V for Vendetta with like
Weird Al Yankovic curls right like so
shorter length curls but then he had the
curly thing in the [ __ ] faith and
he's fat right and then he's out here
like doing his work and he's in his like
40s so all of us are like in our 20s
here's a weird old guy yeah and he's
doing his thing and he'll stop and he
says last night when I was
time-traveling I came across the other
realm and this and you would just go off
into these rats and everyone's like
increasingly monsters and he would
always do these things but a professor
wasn't scared of them so he just be like
hey hey hey hey hey cool it any people
like isn't it weird how like like I hear
that without context he just saying that
[ __ ] out my gall boy turn my brain off
this guy's [ __ ] crazy
yeah but I'm listening to Joe Rogan and
it's like so I was on DMT and I'm like
oh yeah what happened okay yeah it's
like these aliens came up to me I'm like
oh that's [ __ ] interesting but at
least he's talking to someone
sure this guy's [ __ ] doing his thing
and he's talking to the air he stops and
he stops his working he goes so when I
was time-traveling the other day that's
all they could psycho with this tweet
yeah it's [ __ ] nuts and everyone's
like who the [ __ ] is he talking to I
like the teacher the most where it's
like yeah talking about quasars and
shenyu just like calm down like hey
settle down I like it cool it cool
[Music]